you know i want to compliment you i saw
this picture of you
uh and it's uh from teenage uh bounty
hunters and
you're in sick shape you must work out
constantly
five times a week uh each day is a
different body part
and um you know i'm learning a lot about
myself i'm learning my limitations if
anything can humble you in this world
it's the gym please believe that
yes what i do because clearly you and i
work out about the same
hold for laughter
but my question is my question is this
what i do it helps me a lot to listen to
music it motivates me do you ever listen
to your music
while you're working out yes i do
sometimes not too much but i like to
listen to more of my current stuff
i listen to spotify so i just let the
playlist play
so i get a feel of what's today what's
yesterday and
from the far past a lot of the music
today though
i have to admit i didn't like it at
first because i was more into my 90s
stuff
but the more i listened the more i
understood these kids got something
going on man i i applaud them and i have
to applaud excellence they're doing it
it is i think sometimes it's just
natural
as you go on you're always it's very
easy to get stuck
it's very easy to get stuck in no this
is the way it's the same thing with
comedy
i can think no this is what comedy is
and you've got to keep
watching the new people coming up and
you've got to be paying attention to
what they're doing
and still sometimes i'll think sometimes
no
i don't like that but then there are
other so many times when i think
that person's fantastic you know i mean
we kind of
nominate ourselves as uh the gatekeepers
of the art form whereas there are no
gatekeepers this thing
always changes it always develops and it
always has something
new someone's going to breathe fresh air
into it you just wish it was you